Also, let me say, I'm sorry, I know I'm going to be a little bit of an asshole here, but
I'm kind of a little bit of an asshole as a mentor.
I'm like, oh, okay, so this is your dream.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Why aren't you doing that?
You know, like, that's just a little bit of who I am as a mentor.
Best part of acting when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
Yeah, right.
Oh, yeah, dude.
Sup, hackers.
So Zero Trust World just happened and ThreatLocker dropped some pretty cool stuff.
My favorite of the bunch was ThreatLocker Cloud Control, and I'll tell you why, okay?
So when you're trying to hack an organization nowadays, what's kind of like the go-to approach?
Well, for most, it's going to be set up Evil Engine X and send out a bunch of phishing emails,
right?
That way you don't have to worry about two-factor authentication or anything like that, because
Evil Engine X is just going to let them put in their password, their 2FA, and then just hand
you back a session token to interact with Microsoft 365.
So ThreatLocker realized this was a problem, and so what they decided to do was build Cloud Control,
which uses the ThreatLocker agent to sync into Microsoft Cloud conditional access, a list of
approved IP addresses from which a user can connect, right?
So then an attacker gets that token that they stole via Evil Engine X, they try to use it to
interact with Microsoft 365, and boom, they're burned because they're not coming from a permitted
network and they lose access.
It's pretty sick.
It's a great solution to the problem.
So definitely check it out, ThreatLocker Cloud Control.
All right, back to the show.
Alrighty, my man.
Here we go.
We've got the studio set up.
This is the first time we've done a podcast in the new studio live, so I'm excited.
So, for everyone who doesn't know, this is So Sakaguchi.
He's one of my best friends when I lived in Japan and has become a hacker, a full-time bug bounty
hunter over the past couple of years.
And that's been a really fun story.
So he's actually in town doing some hacking with me, visiting, that sort of thing.
And I figured we would do a little podcast to sort of talk about your experience as a becoming a full
time bug bounty hunter from zero before.
And yeah, and I think it was episode 40, if the notes are correct, back in 2023 that you joined the
podcast, came on the podcast with Kodai.
And we started talking about bug bounty mentorship.
So we'll do a little bit of that today.
And we're going to do a live mentorship session and just kind of do a check-in.
And then we'll kind of hit some of the other stuff that as you've grown as a hacker has become more
relevant to this podcast.
So, dude, I'm so excited to have you on here, like as a guest.
And I mean, as a guest, as a guest, like we were sort of debating before, before the podcast
started, like, you know, yes, we could take an angle for this podcast where we could talk about
you mostly as a as a mentee and do like a mentee check in and we will do that.
But also I'm looking at this stuff here and this is good shit, dude.
This is like this is stuff that I would invite you on the podcast to talk about.
So this is the first time that I'm going to have you do this.
But, you know, when we have somebody on the podcast, they have to prove their worth first.
Okay.
Uh, and you have to present a bug.
Present a bug.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, but, and I'll, I'll tell you, I'll tell you this, you know, obviously doing this in English
is a gift to me.
So thank you.
So, and because of that, and also because I have a life dream of doing a podcast in Japanese,
um, we are going to switch at the end of this episode, uh, into Japanese.
And I will also present a bug so that I will understand the difficulty of what you're about to go through.
Um, that's kind of more scary to me too.
Cause you know, I kind of have to lead that, you know, for you.
So, but you also do what Bug Bounty JP podcast.
Is that what it is?
But that's where like, there's another guy leading the conversation.
Yeah.
I just talk.
So it's the difference.
But anyways, not too different.
All right.
Let's, uh, let's, let's jump in.
Which bug you want to start with?
You got a Google and a Facebook bug, which I think is great.
So which, which one you want to, which one you want to start with?
Uh, I think, uh, probably, uh, maybe with Facebook bug, cause I think it's a lot simpler.
Yeah.
Let's do it.
So the Facebook bug is, um, it's like, I'm a little scared with like presenting this bug.
Cause you know, I've seen many people put in the box here and this, this is like,
this is cool.
Cause I found it on Facebook, but it's not too complicated.
But anyways, so, uh, I found this, but this is a store dome XSS that I found on one of their
open source projects, Xcasual.
So the, the reason I, I started to look into this is so for one, uh, I think it was space
Raccoon.
Yeah.
We found some pretty sick, like click board.
Was it like, uh, yeah.
Paste like a clipboard.
Yeah.
XSS.
And he found like pretty cool XSS, like, uh, probably
three, four years ago.
Mm-hmm
I made a blog post about it.
So I knew the product.
And then like last year I read somebody's blog post.
I forgot whose blog post, but it was also about XSS and Xcasual.
And that.
So clearly they have a problem with XSS.
Yeah.
And that one compared to space Raccoon's blog was, it was a great read, but at the same
time it wasn't technically as complex as space Raccoon's one.
I was like actually kind of impressed or surprised that, you know, Facebook has this
level of problem.
It was like, you know, like it gave you a little bit of hope, right?
Yeah.
And then, and plus, uh, I forgot the context, but I met like a manager of Meta Bagbani program
back in like last December, because he came to Japan for, for his work.
Cool.
And, and then he was like, oh, Facebook is not as hard as you think.
And I'm like, well, I don't know about that.
I doubt that.
You know, that's right when I saw the Xcasual blog and I kind of wanted to do a bit of a,
source code review.
So I was like, maybe I'll give it a try.
And the bug was so stored, stored, no, makes this one.
And so I started to look into just all the like things where they do like string concatenation.
It doesn't happen a lot of times, but I just found one thing where they, they do a bit of
string concatenation when they like convert SVG to Xcasual.
Yeah.
Xcasual is, uh, to give it a bit of context, it's, um, uh, like whiteboard app.
It's like, you can, you can, it's a web app where you can like draw different shapes
and like create graphics.
Yeah.
Right.
And then within that app, uh, you've got many different like shapes, graphics that you can use.
Um, and you can import them and they have like dot Xcasual extension too.
Mm.
And the, the string concatenation I found was where they convert SVG into Xcasual extension.
And first I wasn't sure like where they like using it, but I was like, so let's check out
like where they're using it.
And I found that, um, it seems like they allow user to, um, how to explain it.
Like they allow user to export like import their own, um, drawing or the drawing object.
By specifying, uh, like host or like, I forgot the three parameters name, but like something like
host great parameters.
So if you do like import slash import question mark post equal your domain.com.
And if you host, Xcasual object there with SVG and they import it and then make it into Xcasual object.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
So you, there's a slash import endpoint.
You can provide a host for it.
I'm not sure if it was a slash import, but like something like that.
And then it will, it will reach out to your host grab.
Is it just any file type or is it specifically for SVGs?
I think it was, uh, I should have reviewed that.
Like, now you, but I think there's.
Like a few types and then like depending on like the content and also like on content type,
like they'll like triage it.
And then they'll, they'll sort it into and a different Xcalid draw object.
Yeah.
And, and so going back just real quick, I wanted to go back to what you were saying
before with regards to string concatenation.
So you said you were looking for string concatenation.
Were you looking for like specifically HTML, like strings and then concatenating it with a variable
or what was your approach to find that sync in the first place?
I think, uh, so.
Um, so, so it's kind of complicated.
It's like, but, uh, so basically for the, so they, they're, uh, essentially a whiteboard object,
a whiteboard app.
And on whiteboard, everything is canvas canvas, like HTML canvas.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's no SVG, like there's no.
Possibility for accesses, but for like, they have this library feature where they can,
you can store your own or like, you know, imported objects and then put it into your canvas,
into your whiteboard.
And in whiteboard, nothing happens, but within library, like within preview, which is a different
future, but you know, right.
Some future uses like SVG and such, like temporarily to display, like it goes over some
sites.
So I was like, I need to find place where like this, you know, this happens.
And yeah, that was my approach.
That, and that was the approach.
Okay.
So then you find the place where the string concatenation occurs.
You figure out a way to load your, uh, malicious file into the, the person's account.
So if you just hit, make them hit that import, you know, C-Surf essentially, it'll grab the object
from your host and then just kind of plop it into their whiteboard.
Yeah.
No, prop into their library.
Their library.
So it doesn't trigger right off the bat, but once they open library, like every time they open
library, that like object is like made into, um, like X-casual object with HTML, without canvas
tag, cause it's not whiteboard.
Right.
Yeah.
Then, I know it's not whiteboard.
It's a library.
Ah.
And then they trigger XSS.
Okay.
So, so, you know, when it's in the whiteboard, it's in a canvas, so no XSS, but when they go to
the library, there's like a, a preview or something like that, and that uses a different format,
like a SVG or something like that.
To display it.
And that's where you get the XSS.
Nice dude.
Very solid.
All right.
Like maybe I, I, I don't actually remember like too much of the details.
So maybe something was wrong about it, but I think that's pretty much.
That sounds about right.
Now, now was it, you know, at the end of the day, were you able to specify arbitrary HTML
tags or were you just injecting like an onload handler or into the SVG tag or what?
Just like, uh, like image like on there.
Sort of thing.
That, that works.
Clean payload.
Yeah.
I didn't check like any recently from there, but that worked.
Wow.
Dude.
Very nice.
All right.
Well, see, you know, but think about it, man.
You were saying like you read space or King's blog and you read this other person's blog
about Excalibur and you're like, Oh, you know, this doesn't seem so bad.
Right.
And then you had the confidence to go find it and you get a bounty and you find a cool,
you know, vulnerability.
Right.
You're doing the same thing for all the guests now.
You know, they say, Oh yeah, there was an import parameter and then it just, you know, populates
this SVG, you know, on the library page.
That's a, that doesn't seem so bad.
Yeah.
So yeah.
So if you say that I have to do the same thing as all the other guests is like, I said it like
as it, as if, as if it was easy, but it was like before finding this thing.
Yeah.
I think it took me like four days finding that thing like, Oh, this turns out to be not vulnerable.
And then like, on 4th, 5th day I was like, Oh, what is this thing?
Yeah.
We just had this earlier or like what yesterday, right?
You spent like four hours.
I'm sorry to call you out, but we were hacking together yesterday and there was like, you know,
there was a post message, uh, that we saw come through on one of these targets.
And we, we love to see a post message that contains a raw HTML string.
Like, doesn't that just like get the blood flowing a little bit?
Like exactly.
We saw it.
Yeah.
And, and so, so like we get excited, we're like, Oh, this is going to be excess.
You know, they got a campaign going on.
This is going to be easy money.
And, um, and so, so like goes through this whole process to like build an HTML page and
like do this handshake with the post message.
And then we get to the end of it and it's like, what is it like react?
And they use react to be like, we build HTML.
And there's nothing we can do about that.
You know, like, it's just, I won't give up yet.
Yeah.
So, well, we recently also, you know, we'll talk about this as well.
Um, but we also had a couple of things sort of like this in a Google bug recently, um,
where we had a post message to HTML injection, um, on the page.
But when you just get, when you get stuck in these like react sanitize or angular sanitize
functions, it's like, if you can bypass angular or react sanitize, then that's the bigger problem.
You know, like you don't need to worry about reporting your little post message bug.
You need to report angular sanitize bypass.
Right.
Um, but it was interesting because, you know, just like you said, you're not giving up.
Um, that episode that we did with Kevin Mizu and Kevin Mizu's, um, write up recently on like how
to bypass Dom purify or via misconfigurations and stuff like that was really eye opening for me on
how to attack HTML sanitizers.
Um, and just try to take advantage of the fact that if there is any modification that is done
to the string post sanitization, that you're, you're messing with it, right?
You know, you're messing with the integrity of that, of that sanitize.
Um, so that's one of the things I always go to look for.
So I won't blame you because I also went down the rabbit hole auditing angular sanitize on this
Google bug.
Um, but yeah, it seems pretty hopeless whenever you're in a sort of angular react sanitize situation.
We have to say so.
Yeah.
All right.
So that was one you got to pass, but actually number two, we're going to, we're actually going
to do two bugs today.
This bug was actually a collaboration between So and I on a Google target.
And, um, we're, we may have to cut this segment right now.
We'll see.
Uh, you know, if, if we do, I'm sorry, hopefully we'll get the chance to talk about it sometime.
Um, but, um, I guess we'll cut now if we do not get permission to disclose this.
Um, all right.
So if you're still listening to this, we do have permission to disclose it, which rocks.
So, um, so let's go ahead and jump into it.
Um, do you want to tag team this one or you want to take a shot at it or what?
Um, I think I'll try to explain first and then you jump in if I, if my, my explanation is not clear.
All right.
Hit us.
Yeah.
So the thing we found was, um, um, wait, I'm not sure how, how much we, how much it
do we can go into, but, uh, so.
Don't say, don't say where we find it.
Found it.
You can say Google and then technical details, but don't say what product we found it in.
Yeah.
So the first Justin found some like interesting feature in Google, like that's like pretty much
that's used pretty much everywhere in Google products.
Like regardless of like Google.com, YouTube.com like, you know, different domains.
And so that this is so hard to do.
Like, all right.
Do you, why don't you let me queue it up?
Okay.
And then you talk about the technical details.
Cause it is a little bit difficult when you're trying not to disclose some information.
So this is a Google, um, this is a component used by a bunch of Google products.
Uh, like you said on YouTube, on Google, on, you know, any of their domains.
Um, and, um, for the business use case, which we can't say it is essential that it be able
to be used on all of these different, um, domains.
And, um, it creates an iframe and it does some stuff with that iframe.
Uh, and what we are trying to, to take advantage of here is that this product has to be so versatile.
So, um, universally accessible, um, because it makes doing origin checks really difficult.
Um, and allows us to sort of insert ourselves as, uh, as a parent or as a, um, you know, as a window
in the same, um, tab group as the specific frame, which allowed us to get access to the post message
handlers, which allowed us to send some post messages.
So, um, then we've sort of teed it up there now you can kind of try to take it and explain some
of the technical details.
Yeah.
So, so basically like, like Justin said, it's like an, uh, iframe where it receives, um,
like some information, like some information from Google related domains, Google related services,
I'd say.
It's like a configuration post message.
Yeah.
And then based off of those information received, the iframe sends a, like, like a few requests
to Google API to do, you know, to send stuff and such.
Mm-hmm .
And that's, that's like the kind of overview, how I see it.
And so we, we found this post message on the Franz Rosen post message tracker.
Shout out to Franz.
And shout out to Franz Rosen.
And that post message, uh, that post message content included like bunch of different stuff
that looks like a component of HTTP request.
Mm.
Yeah.
And I think what was interesting about this is it, and you did a really good job of it
as we were building it out because, uh, it was protobuf format, right?
It didn't have like keys and values.
It was just like an array with values.
Yeah.
And, um, and then, Oh yeah.
And I, I kind of let you be and work on this for a little bit while I was working on this
other bug.
Yeah.
And then I came back and man, I just loved to see it.
And then I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I
So like Justin said, I kind of tried to like understand how each component works, how each component is being used.
And yeah, like you said, it wasn't initially clear that it's something to build HTTP requests.
But as I go through the JavaScript, I just realized, oh, this is, you know, this is HTTP path, or this is, you know, body, and this is a query parameter.
So what we found out is with a lot of restrictions, we could potentially send post message from our site to that iframe.
In a way that that iframe sends like partially controlled HTTP requests to Google API.
And one good thing about like one good thing about for us is that some of the things or some of the things that we don't have control.
on include authorization header.
So for that, like partially controlled requests includes victims authorization header.
And the other thing that was interesting was, uh, if the, the request is successful, the response is sent back by the post message.
You love to see it.
Yeah.
Freaking love to see it, man.
So what we can do is like kind of see surfing, but at the same time, we can see the response back to love it.
With, with victim, so there's a header sent.
So, so that was our attack vector is like, we tried to find, to hit an endpoint that, uh, the response with like users information or something like that.
Mm-hmm .
And we read that, that, that, that was our attack vector.
And then, yeah, that was over.
And then we, then we sort of hit into a roadblock with this, uh, domain validation.
Yeah.
So we, that was the first block, which is a domain validation.
So the, the first time I saw this post message listener, there's no origin check.
So I was like, okay, so, you know, I don't even have to think about that.
Yeah.
So I'll just, uh, think about the, the request content.
And then once I figured out the request content, I realized that they're actually sending two requests instead of one request.
Mm-hmm .
And, uh, the first request is like slash domain, uh, question mark, domain equal your domain, like original post message.
And then second domain is like the one we can read the response.
Yeah.
And now apparently they were using that first request as a domain check.
Right.
So, so essentially they had, instead of doing like the domain check at the, at the post message level, they were taking our origin, sticking it in a, in a domain parameter.
Yeah.
And then hitting an API to tell them whether or not we should be allowed to access this or be able to send this post message.
Right.
Which kind of makes sense too.
Cause like, like we mentioned this, like component was used everywhere.
Mm-hmm .
Not just on google.com.
So, you know, you want to keep it like a versatile.
Yeah.
Like easy to configure.
So they, they might want it to configure this way instead of, you know, checking origin.
Sure.
And so we keep that, uh, that block, but, uh, one, one thing I realized that is, uh, for the first request, not just the second request, the first request for domain check, we have just a bit of control on that first request too, which is right parameter.
Mm-hmm .
So we could, uh, specify query parameter.
So like, you know, obviously the first thing I was thinking was like, well, maybe if I specify domain equal google.com.
Mm-hmm .
They might override like domain equal my domain.com.
And then they might give me, you know, they might pass the check.
So it would become like a request to slash check domain.
Oh yeah.
And then it would say question mark domain equals google.com.
That's the one we specify.
And then hash.
And then, oh, you were going to try to truncate that.
Yeah.
So put like a hashtag.
So you truncate off that and domain equals attacker site.com.
Yeah.
So I didn't explain this as well, but like, yes.
So in that post message, we could have just specified, uh, uh, HCTM, HTTP request query parameter, uh, key value pair.
Yeah, sure.
And those things come before the like domain equal my domain.com.
So I was like, if we can put hash in it, we could override it.
Mm.
Truncate the path.
Yeah.
Or the query parameters.
And then Steve, we can send this request and we might potentially be able to, you know, exputure something.
Mm-hmm .
But that turned out to be, uh, that didn't work.
Right.
And the reason for that is, uh, so we read the JavaScript and they're doing more thorough approach of just taking out,
all the key value parameter and create an array, like array and object.
And then at the end of the array, they have their, you know, check thing domain equal my domain.com.
Mm-hmm .
And then, so, so they, they put all of them like one by one.
And during that process, because domain equal my domain.com is at the last, that always overwrites, like, even if I attempt like domain.com before, you, you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So they set them in a map, right?
So domain, and then, and then, you know, the value.
Yeah.
They parse all of our parameters.
And then at the end they say, override whatever is, is there with domain equals whatever.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
So we could send like, there is something invalid equal something invalid and domain equal my domain.com.
Yeah.
But we couldn't override that domain parameter.
Right.
Okay.
So we're still stuck there.
Yeah.
How did you get around it?
So.
So that was, I, it wasn't like, you know, like strategical, like thoughtful approach.
I just, you know, you know, I'm just gonna, you know, dump all the, like characters using it, like work computer and put that thing right before the D of domain and right after N of domain.
Yeah.
And see if those will pass.
Because we tried also like capitalization and stuff like that.
Right.
But the capitalization wouldn't let us to, wouldn't let us get back by it.
It was like lower casing everything or something.
Yeah.
And I was kind of at that point, I was like, that was like full place.
Like attempt.
Yeah.
I know it not, that's not gonna work, but I'm just gonna do it.
And then, and then when I see that, when I saw the like intruder history, I saw some, some of them sucks.
Being successful, like including one like dot domain equal, uh, like Google.com.
In which case they say like dot domain equal Google.com and domain equal my domain.com.
Right.
And I don't know what the heck happens on backend, but like if I send that like three times or four times, and then like one of them succeeds.
Dude.
Like for like whatever reason.
I remember when you found that and then we, I think it was actually like literally right here.
In this exact spot.
So it was like sitting over there.
He says, Justin, I got it.
No, you're upstairs.
I was upstairs.
I run down here.
You show me it.
And then we just start jumping up and down and screaming.
It was like, no way that that works.
It's crazy to me, man, that it worked like, what was it like 30% of the time?
Like there was some weird load balancer in there where it was like, okay, I'm one of these like four servers or whatever is gonna.
T strip the, the dot character from the beginning of the.
Maybe so.
Super weird.
Yeah.
I have no idea what happens backend, but it's worth it.
The problem is, you know, we, we don't know yet what we can do with, you know, us being able to send.
Partially control parameter to specific Google private API.
Right.
Cause we haven't figured that for hours.
So it's not, it's not like a super win yet, but that was still pretty exciting.
Yeah.
So it took us like three days to come to like domain check thing.
Cause because of three days work, we were so excited and then we go, we gotta push, push through the, all the, all the, you know, blocks to come in the future.
So that's the, that was the first block.
Mm.
And Moses.
So the, so from there, then we, we established that we were able to communicate with this post message handler and trigger these, these requests to the API that we wanted to do and get the responses back.
Right.
Yeah.
If the request is successful.
Right.
So yeah.
Then at that point, so because of some restriction, we couldn't bypass, uh, there are only like a few API, Google API we could hit.
Mm.
And we kind of numerate all the, all the pretty query using like a Google discovery document.
Mm-hmm.
And so we pretty much found nothing.
Uh, except one API get based request, reserving email.
Mm-hmm.
And sad thing is our request is post based.
And we couldn't change post to get that, that was something we couldn't control.
Right.
And then.
Yeah.
And, and, and then from there, I think, since it was, it was post, we had to figure out a way to hit these different API endpoints though.
Right.
And then we, before we did that.
And if I recall correctly, that happened via a client side path traversal.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So, so that's, that's another block I completely skipped here.
There is a, so like, like mentioned, like some of the things could be configurable.
Mm.
Some of the things in HTTP, because they're configurable, including HTTP path.
Mm-hmm.
So, like part of HTTP path.
Yeah.
Just one segment.
One like ID is something we had control of.
Mm-hmm.
And they're using XHR on the client side, and they don't have any validation before that.
So we could inject like . . . to traverse back to the root.
Mm-hmm.
So, which allowed us to send pretty much whatever, to whatever endpoints.
We don't have control on host, but we had control of any, like the path being sent.
Any of the paths.
So that's why we could keep arbitrarily, uh, endpoint of, of given.
Yeah.
And, and, but then we're still stuck with the post request.
We looked at the discovery documents, couldn't find anything we could do with the post request.
Right.
Yeah.
So, so then what happened?
Then like, there, like, uh, we started to do some like hopeless attempts again.
Like, I, I think I spent like four hours on that.
Yeah.
And one thing I found, which turned out to be absolutely useless is like, I found like this
X method override header.
Yeah.
If I send it, like Google will accept.
Like if I send post, post request with X, uh, method override header.
We get, they will say as yet.
So I was like, Oh, if I can space with this header, then like, uh, that we are victorious.
The thing is we can't add any parameter like header.
Yeah.
That wasn't something you have control and such.
So that, that took us like what?
Like probably pretty much a day.
Yeah.
A day on that.
I think.
Yeah.
And then there, I almost completely gave up there.
And then Justin moves on to, um, completely different target.
But like Google, right?
Yeah.
But I was still looking at Google.
And then I think I, I still remember it was like 11 o'clock in the morning.
Yeah.
And then I was like, like, decided that you were like, Oh, I got this.
So, and then, you know, he, what he found is like, um, RPC.
Yeah.
So, so essentially what, what it turned out to be was that all, almost all of Google's
APIs are accessible by multiple, uh, ways you can, you can hit, you know, the path
strategically like a, like a normal rest API, you know, slash API slash whatever.
Um, and then hit those endpoints with get post whatever, or you can use the RPC interface.
Yeah.
Um, and, and the RPC interface has some quirks to it, but one of the things that works really
well for us is that it's all post based.
Right.
Yeah.
But the other thing that doesn't work for us is they use a little bit different
for about content type.
Yeah.
So we actually tried that.
Right.
Yeah.
We've already like tried hitting RPC endpoints.
Didn't work cause content types are different.
That's like, you know, three days before you screen.
Right.
Right here.
So what was the final discovery then?
That was your discovery.
So.
Okay.
Final discovery was this guys, was that, um, on some Google APIs that utilize RPC,
there is a header that you, or a, a queer parameter that you can provide called
$http headers with a capital H for headers.
Um, and what that allows you to do is just specify arbitrary HTTP headers, which was exactly what we needed.
So, you know, putting that whole chain together, what we ended up doing was changing the content type then to the correct protobuf content type, hitting an RPC endpoint with a post request, which is exactly how it's supposed to be.
And with the path to reversal.
Right.
And the path to reversal, right.
And to hit the RPC endpoints.
And then we specified, uh, we also had full control of the body of the request from the, the, the poster or from the post message.
Yeah.
So then putting it all together, bypass the dot domain check, hit the client side path to reversal, traverse to the RPC call, uh, specify the HTTP headers to convert the content type to a protobuf.
And then send a protobuf in the body to missend a valid protobuf request to the API, which then gets piped back out via post message to our, our, our, uh, our handler.
Yeah.
And then that handle obviously was like sends the resources back to our site.
Yep.
Via post message.
So really users like, you know, some information.
Yeah.
Some information.
We were able to then use that to do a bunch of things.
One, you know, we could leak some PAI about the user.
We could also modify, like make the user send a specific type of, um, object to the API that would change their account.
And we could also extract a bunch of data, not only about the user, but about these, uh, objects that they have in this API.
Um, so that was a really fun bug.
Dude, give me some, man.
That was, that was a blast.
Um, very fun collab.
Okay.
We, we took some time on that one.
Um, but let's go ahead and, uh, move to some of these other sections that we have, um, in the, in the doc for today.
Um, you want to do the live mentorship session now, or do you want to talk about reflector first?
The live mentorship.
Let's do that one first.
Okay.
All right.
So let's, so, so let me kind of set the stage for this a little bit.
Like, like I've said before, I do some occasional buggani mentorship, but it's pretty much only for people that I know in real life.
Um, and, or are, you know, providing a service to the podcast or, you know, something like that.
There's some other exchange of services.
Um, shout out to, to, uh, Andrew, uh, ninjeter who did my tattoo for me in exchange for some mentorship.
Um, and when we do these mentorship sessions, a lot of the time, what I'm spending time doing is figuring out, you know, what my mentees want to do with their bug bounty career and helping them get there.
And it doesn't necessarily have to be, you know, bug bounty is, is the full goal as we'll talk about later today.
It could also be bug bounty as a stepping stone to get somewhere else in your career.
Um, so I don't know.
So we haven't sort of compared notes on this in a little while.
And even though you're here in person, like things have been really busy lately.
So we haven't had the chance to sit down much.
So I'm glad we're getting the chance to do that now on a pod.
Um, you, I guess five years ago, you were a French major at school and, you know, we met and, uh, you know, you got interested in hacking and you since totally changed your career path and are now full-time bug bounty hunter.
Um, but before you were in, you know, consulting for a little bit as a pen tester, um, with some companies in Japan.
So that's kind of, uh, your history.
Uh, you've been doing full-time bug bounty for how long now?
For, uh, eight months.
Eight months.
Okay.
And you, you made that transition from a pretty, uh, well-respected, uh, Japanese consultancy, you know, uh, in Japan.
Um, how are you feeling about that transition?
Where do you want to be?
You know, what are your goals for bug bounty and your security career?
Um, I think so for, for the first question of like, how was the transition?
Um, I think, uh, for one, it was a good transition.
Um, the thing I like, so there are things that I like better about bug bounty and like better about, you know, working as full-time contester.
Mm.